heute hat jens spahn in einem interview
gesagt dass sämtliche corona
einschränkungen erst im nächsten
frühjahr beendet werden könnten weil es
dann eine herten immunität erreicht
werden könnte also kein freedom day ende
oder anfang oktober wie beispielsweise
vom chef der vereinigung der kassen
ärzte gefordert und so richtig
ungemütlich könnte der winter für nicht
geimpfte werden ungeimpfte sollen kein
krankengeld mehr bekommen wenn sie in
quarantäne gehen darauf haben sich nach
bild information jetzt alle bundesländer
geeinigt wer in behördlich angeordneter
quarantäne ist und nicht geimpft ist er
bekommt keine entschädigung auch der
arbeitgeber muss für diese zeit nichts
mehr zahlen gelten soll das ganze ab dem
11 oktober und wir fragen unsere bild
live chef claus strunz er klaus bin ich
mir überlege wie oft ich schon in
quarantäne war und dann kein geld dafür
bekommen würde ist das noch legitim aus
meiner sicht nicht also ich finde diese
jagd auf ungeimpfte die die regierung
jetzt anzettelt dieses die ungeimpfte zu
minder zu einer minderheit zu
stigmatisieren und sie zu bestrafen
durch maßnahmen also wir müssen uns
einfach mal vorstellen das ist jetzt der
nächste hammer dass kein krankengeld
oder kein geld ausbezahlt wird in
behördlich verordnete quarantäne also es
ist ja nicht dass leute in quarantäne
gehen weil es so lustig ist sondern sie
gehen weil sie müssen und was noch viel
verrückter ist die allermeisten menschen
die in quarantäne gehen haben gar kein
kroner also gesunde menschen werden vom
staat in quarantäne geschickt und dann
sollen sie kein geld bekommt das ist
finde ich der nächste schritt einer
krone politik der mehr als umstritten
ist er eigentlich abzulehnen ist und ich
habe auch noch ein punkt der mich dabei
extrem aufmerksam macht und deshalb bin
ich froh dass wir da auch genau
hingucken wir leben in einem land in dem
wir mit gutem recht das n wort nicht
mehr aussprechen wollen wo wir auf
unsere sprache achten weil wir
minderheiten nicht stigmatisieren wollen
wir sagen nur mit ganz ganz großer
aufmerksamkeit und am besten gar nicht
ausländer schwuler und jetzt fängt diese
regierung an eine neue minderheit zu
kreieren und beschimpft sie gleich
selbst als gefahr nämlich ungeimpfter du
ungeimpfte das ist das neue schimpfwort
dass diese regierung in umlauf bringt
durch ihre politik ungeimpft die leben
doch bestimmt mit anderen ungeimpften in
zu kleinen wohnungen ungeimpfte aha
kannst du dein kind eigentlich zu einem
ungeimpften auf eine party schicken dein
kind europa ist diese bestimmung gilt
wenn der ansatz der ungeimpfte der
ungeimpfte ist das neue sticker und das
ist das gegenteil einer gesellschaft in
der ich leben will ungeimpfte sind
sozusagen die neuen n ihr wisst was ich
meine das macht mich wirklich da müssen
das so aufmerksam sein weil das klingt
ja alle schlechten dinge die wir in dem
land schon erlebt haben an und es steht
nicht dafür weil es ist ja keine gefahr
es ist ja in einer zeit in der korona
gebannt ist auch wenn jens spahn jetzt
sagt es ist bis nächstes frühjahr können
die maßnahmen nicht fallen das ist ja
eine mutter wie sagt man vorsicht ist
die mutter der porzellankiste über den
wahltag jetzt bloß kein fehler machen
der noch irgendwie an es gibt aber kein
fehler wenn man jetzt ein freedom day
machen würde die pandemie ist überwunden
wir müssen es aussprechen sie es
überwunden es gibt noch fälle und die
haben wir im griff weil jetzt unser
logistik sozusagen darauf eingestellt
ist und wer jetzt ungeimpfte
stigmatisiert der verändert dieses land
und die kultur in diesem land und
schafft ein gesellschaftliches klima in
dem das was überwunden werden soll
nämlich minderheiten anzuklagen
minderheiten auszugrenzen minderheiten
zu stigmatisieren von der regierung
betrieben aufs neue geschieht nicht
macht das ängstlich und wütend ja immer
argumentiert und das sehen ja auch viele
in der bevölkerung so die sich haben
impfen lassen es gibt ein impfangebot
für jeden warum soll also die
allgemeinheit dann sozusagen die
verantwortung für die übernehmen die
sich nicht impfen lassen das ist das ist
ein gutes starkes argument und um es
auch zu sagen ich bin geimpft und ich
würde auch jedem raten sich impfen zu
lassen aber mein freiheitsgefühl sagt
man kann die anderen die es nicht machen
wollen nicht in dieser weise behandeln
und unterdrücken und dem argument würde
ich entgegnen die allgemeinheit bezahlt
schon für ganz schön viel andere risiken
mit wenn jemand am wochenende fußball
spielt im amateur verein und bricht sich
den haxen dann bezahlen alle anderen
kranken für sie hätten auch seine
ausfallzeit mit das nennt man
solidargemeinschaft und beim impfen
schaffen wir die solidargemeinschaft ab
das ist eigentlich die politische
wichtigkeit dieser debatte und ich
erwarte auch dass die sozusagen
aufgewühlt geführt wird denn es geht
hier nicht darum eine impfmuffel
minderheit auch diese begrifflichkeiten
sind schon so irgendwie zu noch dazu zu
kriegen sie kämpfen zu lassen es ist ein
autoritärer akt des staates gegen eine
minderheit
[Musik]